[Musique]
bonjour l'actualité européenne nous vous
la faisons vivre malgré le confinement
et oui votre émission europe hebdo
s'adapte et on retrouve tout de suite
sandro gozi eurodéputés lrm élus en
france vous avez d'ailleurs été
conseiller d'edouard philippe sur les
affaires européennes et vous avez été
également secrétaire d'état du
gouvernement de matteo renzi en italie
tout d'abord comment se passe votre
confinement où vous trouvez vous je me
trouve à paris je me trouve à paris et
bah elle manque en confinement ça se
passe comme poules et les français les
européens
je bouge beaucoup entre les séjours la
cuisine la chambre et j'ai fait beaucoup
d'activités entre un tapis roulant et un
mac avec vous nous avez envoyé des
photos d'ailleurs on vous voit faire du
sport c'est important d'en faire
quotidiennement de des conseils
peut-être pour rester en forme durant ce
confinement
c'est fondamental c'est fondamental même
pour les non sportifs de faire du sport
à paris on peut faire avant 10 heures ou
après 19 heures évidemment penser qu'ils
ont font régulièrement ils savent déjà
ce qu'il faut faire penser qui s élance
maintenant attention attention doucement
parce que ça je dis rien à beaucoup ça
peut faire mal
vous êtes loin de votre famille restée
en italie c'est pas dur dur cet
éloignement sûr c'est dur c'est dur
parce que en plus nos familles un peu
éparpillée entre 1000 et romagne et rome
et les pouilles et donc c'est pas ça ça
ajoute un peu à la difficulté de ces
documents mais en étant élu en france
j'y suis resté ici jusqu'à la fin et je
suis resté ici maintenant en essayant
d'y contribuer en tant que député
européen et de mon appartement il sait
pas sandro gozi on va aborder notre
premier thème le déconfinement la france
se prépare un dea confinement à partir
du 11 mai l'italie à partir du 4 mai
c'est pas un peu prématuré selon vous
non j'ai non il faut faire confiance à
aux évaluations qui est les experts et
les gouvernements font évidemment
personne n'a de certitude c'est que
comme le confinement c'est des choses
qui n'a n'est jamais arrivé avant né de
confinement aussi cet exercice
complètement
en gros je crois que c'est important
d'aider d'y réfléchir de les préparer et
évidemment ça sera à intégrer des
personnes d'âge des territoires j'ai
quoi mais il faut le faire et il faut
les faire avec une convention européenne
du est alors justement il n'y a pas de
coordination européenne en le
déconfinement il a déjà démarré en
autriche en allemagne au danemark par
exemple c'était impossible de se mettre
d'accord sur un calendrier commun
c'était possible c'était possible à ces
questions et plusieurs des volontés et
c'était aussi possible d entrer dans le
confinement des façons un peu plus
coordonnée la coordination a duré 72
heures on a eu un échange d'informations
préalables qui a duré deux jours et demi
maintenant je crois que au moins des des
principes clairs commun pour les donc
des compliments sont nécessaires parce
que sinon les marché unique et la libre
circulation va pas assez rétablir des
façons efficaces et nous en avons besoin
alors justement l'om est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé a mis en garde
l'europe je vous propose d'écouter son
directeur général nous voulons souligner
à nouveau que l'assouplissement des
restrictions ne signifie la fin de
l'épidémie dans aucun pays pour mettre
fin à l'épidémie
il faudra un effort soutenu de la part
des individus des communautés et des
gouvernements pour continuer à
revendiquer et à contrôler ce virus
mortel
d
avec cette phase de déconfinement amorcé
l'europe prend le risque d'une deuxième
vague de contamination d'épidémie est-ce
que c'est à dire que l'économie passe
avant la santé non ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas cette question c'est que il faut il
faut qu on peut rentrer dans une phase
dans laquelle on gère la question du
virus évidemment ça dépend de la bonne
gestion efficace ça dépendra dé chacun
de nous chacun de nous devra respecter
les règles devra faire croire des sens
civique
alors chacun de nous en tout cas on en
italie pour contrôler la phase de
déconfinement lé respect des règles le
gouvernement a choisi une application
unique qui permettra le traçage des
personnes infectées par le coroner virus
et de leurs contacts ratings qui soulève
de nombreuses questions un respect des
libertés individuelles des données selon
la directive européenne rgp des vous
êtes favorable à ce genre d'application
à ce tracking favorable à deux
conditions qu'il y ait une approche
européenne que ce que césar soit
proportionnelle aux pensionnés à ce
qu'il doit faire et qu'elle soit
volontaire et qu'on ne puisse pas et
créé des stocks des données personnelles
qu'on va garder et c'est là je suis en
ce moment nous sommes en train de faire
en tant que député européen autrement ma
délégation et naissance contraints à
travailler justement pour avoir une
approche commune européenne est
inaltérée opérabilité entre les apps
parce qu'ici chacun a fait son app on a
des problèmes des coopérations
d'efficacité et de circulation des
citoyens et en france visiblement
l'exécutif a promis un cas d'option de
l'application kovy stop qu'ovide serait
volontaire et impliquerait vous des
données totalement anonyme c'est
suffisant selon vous comme garantie tout
d'abord il faut être très clair sur
l'anonymat sur le caractère volontaire
et sur le caractère temporaire vigier
quoique il faut s'assurer que tout ceci
soit respectée à l'échelle à l'échelle
européenne c'est exactement le travail
que je dois faire en ce moment je
comprends pas ce que les apps font
partie d'une bonne gestion et de la
sortie d'une bonne gestion du de
confinement je comprends que chaque
gouvernement veuille se doter des sites
utiles si chacun
une part de son côté ça sera pas
efficace la solidarité européenne at
elle fonctionné depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire
une grande question avant de vous
entendre à ce sujet je voudrais qu'on
écoute un la présidente de la commission
européenne
or si la van der leyen oui c'est vrai
personne n'était vraiment presse il est
vrai aussi que beaucoup n'étaient pas là
lorsque l'italie a eu besoin d'un coup
de main au tout début
eh oui pour cela il est normal que
l'europe dans son ensemble présente des
excuses sincères
mais les excuses ne compte que si cela
change les comportements des mots forts
à un prononcé par ursula von der leyen
l'europe devra doit présenter des
excuses aux italiens oui est la première
à devoir présenter des excuses
cette hausse vers la haye qui a été
catastrophique au départ c'est de cette
crise je m'en souviens des sound et sa
tribune sous les quolibets de la scea
premier quotidien italien dé milan en
plein crise en place en rouge elles
m'ont ce n'est jamais les coronavirus
elle est elle commence à se rattraper la
président de la commission européenne et
c'est bien ainsi
d'après moi les rattrapages va se
mesurer sur sur la base de l'importance
de la taille et du sérieux du grand plan
de relance économique et social sur
lequel est la commission européenne fin
travailler parce qu'il est mon bon bien
messi s'en souvient par les actes
c'est beaucoup mieux vous attendez les
actes le parlement européen lui s'est
prononcé en faveur de plus de solidarité
notamment ce qui concerne la prise en
charge de la dette commune mais une fois
encore un haut niveau des états membres
ça coince moi je crois que on doit
poursuivre cette confrontation politique
l'europe dans les derniers trois
semaines a déjà beaucoup fait on a fait
des choses impensables n'a pris des
mesures un constable elle a déjà misé
années qu'elle est là elle a est
suspendu les paquets stabilité des
croissances en donnant la possibilité au
gouvernement d et lancé des plans
économiques très importants la banque
centrale européenne a mis à lancer à un
plan de plus de 600 500 milliards
d'euros la banque européenne
d'investissement comment à travailler ou
des garanties autour de 240 milliards
d'euros on a introduit une
assurance-chômage européenne
complémentaire assise nationale donc on
a fait beaucoup de choses mais il faut
maintenant poursuit la confrontation
politique parce qu'elle autour d'idées
d'une dette publique européenne il ya
l'idée d'un grand plan d'investissements
communs européens parce qu'ils fassent
qu'on retrouve sur ces questions là tout
même un
des divisions l'europe retombe dans ses
vieux travers avec une division europe
du sud europe du nord
non les divisions sont entre c'est
qu'ils sont encore un trait à un monde d
hier qu'il n'ya plus est ce qu il veut
rentrer dans le monde et des mains et
s'est projeté dans le monde et des mains
donc il ya c'est qui encore pense que
les débats soient et que les
contribuables allemands on doit payer la
dette française italienne c'est pas du
tout ça quand on rentre dont on parle on
part d'un grand plan de relance
économique et social garantis par le
budget de l'union européenne est
financée par des ressources nouvelles
ressources nouvelles cendres au gosier
en tout cas le manque de réponse commune
il fait monter leur scepticisme c'est ce
qui ressort d'un sondage en italie et 71
% des italiens pensent que la pandémie
du corps aux navires me sens détruit
l'union européenne environ 55 % seraient
d'accord pour sortir de nyon de l'euro
c'est catastrophique
ce n'est pas étonnant vu que les
ministres affaires étrangères luigi di
maio qui sait peut-être d'élégie le
jeune mais les portes dans la tête
allait la faire et l'a passé à moi à
faire de l'accompagnement roshi n'est
pas aussi qu'il a caché le fait qu' il
ya eu décès de deux françaises
allemandes et qu'il a on n'a pas bien
informés sur ce qu'est l'europe déjà
fait évidemment les erreurs et où cela
vendeurs la une a fait au début de la
crise de la communication ont énormément
aidés à la propagande nationale antennes
de rossi seulement en italie
mais la propagande nationaliste chinois
et russes on it est une des solutions
peut-être un pour relancer la
construction européenne c'est une europe
plus forte plus politique avec plus de
compétences en matière de santé
notamment c'est ce qui ressort de cette
crise sanitaire
oui et là on s'éclaire selon les
derniers baromètres 70% des européens
des mondes plus d europe dans le domaine
de la santé
ceci vous dire solidarité donc
évidemment si on n'a pas des capacités
d'espagne est dans une crise des
patients dans un état hip hop pouvoir
les relocaliser dans notre état c'est ce
qui s'est passé entre mulhouse la suisse
et luxembourg allemagne que ça fait
souvent été prise de contractions
souveraineté faire a mis un sou le
territoire européen
la production des questions vitales des
des principes
vito procès concerne les questions
descente et pharmaceutique
et ça veut dire plus de coopération
renforcée avoir un véritable force
européenne de santé qu'ils puissent
véritablement coordonnées lectrices trop
nationales comme celles du virus dans la
course mondiale notamment aussi aux
vaccins contre les 19 là il faut que ça
se joue aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne un renforcement des
programmes de recherche
absolument il ya un mois et des murs à
poser une question à la commission
européenne pour lui demander de créer un
consortium européen commun pour la
recherche du vaccin pour contre les cd
19 contre les coronavirus et nous
pensons que comme l'europe avait déjà
élancés pour les années à venir des
missions spécifiques dans la lutte
contre les cancers l'obésité et le
basser émissions spécifiques justement
pour nous aider dans la lutte contre les
gros navires us sandro gozi une dernière
question l'europe d'après coronavirus
elle va ressembler à quoi
emmanuel macron la veut plus ambitieuse
concrètement ça veut dire quoi mener
maquereau a tout à fait raison à nous
demander des penser l'impensable
je crois que jusqu'à maintenant l'europe
a été une association très utile entrée
des états il faut passer à une
communauté solidaire entre peuples et
entre citoyens et là en commençant par
la santé et par la sécurité humaine
tu crois qu'on peut y arriver il faut
poursuivre le débat politique
il faut poursuivre la scène
confrontation politique tout court merci
sandro gozi à bientôt j'espère depuis le
parlement européen
et maintenant direction vienne en
autriche
[Musique]
et chaque semaine nous nous rendons dans
un pays de l'union européenne à la
rencontre d'un citoyen confiné cette
semaine ses veaux luna étudiante franco
allemand que vous effectuez un stage à
vienne depuis le début du mois de mars
en autriche la phase de déconfinement
est entamée depuis une semaine à peu
près ça se passe comment est-ce que
c'est un retour à la vie normale à la
vie d'avant
vrai que depuis le début de mon stage il
y avait beaucoup de changements sachant
que j'ai seulement passé dix jours dans
mon lieu de travail avant de rendre un
compliment
et il faut dire qu'en autriche je pense
que la situation est assez du genre par
différentes par rapport à la france
parce que depuis le début on a eu des
restrictions et on a été prié de rester
à la maison mais on a toujours pu sortir
on a plus se promener il fallait jamais
prouver quoi que ce soit que j'ai pu
quand même visiter des parcs
après on est obligé de rester vraiment
on est demandé de rester avec la
personne avec qui on l'a vite donc
actuellement je suis avec les
colocataires autrichienne et donc depuis
quelques semaines les restrictions nous
a dit que peu à peu ça va s'améliorer y
aura de moins d'un an de réflexion
la deuxième phase où la fin de
destruction débutera en mai et est là
actuellement voilà les supermarchés sont
ouverts on est obligé de porter des
masques
donc il ya encore des gestes barrières
qui sont respectés et le port du masque
est obligatoire c'est ça de plus depuis
deux semaines à peu près il ya les
magasins qui ont moins de 400 mètres
qu'avec un endroit ouvert donc c'est des
petites boutiques c'est des magasins de
deux mines est que je suis récemment
resserré pas de lunettes qui sont
d'accord les restaurants et les bars un
nom les restaurants et les bars
normalement de bons rouvrir à partir de
loulay et comme les écoles et les lycées
et les autrichiens voulait santé
inquiète dissous discipline et dans quel
état d'esprit vous les sentez
l'un plasmique vu qu'on a quand même été
les premiers mots vous nous avez envoyé
des photos on voit notamment beaucoup de
gens dans les parcs là
oui avec on a été les premiers dans
l'union européenne a arrêté en quelque
sorte les restrictions j'ai l'impression
que les autres et chats font assez
positif et donc voilà le temps fait que
je pense que les autrichiens ont un peu
marre de sortie de rester coincés chez
eux donc ils sortent mais il faut quand
même attention donc il ya beaucoup de
gens qui portent les masques au thon
dans les supermarchés que dehors parce
que j'imagine que tout le monde a peur
de se retrouver de nouveau confiné c'est
c'est eh bien écoutez on verra ça dans
les semaines qui viennent merci luna
prenez soin de vous et donnez nous vite
de vos nouvelles
à la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
[Musique]